[Musique]
ce matin-là l'instant est solennel dans
l'hémicycle la gestion de 1,25 milliard
d'euros de budget n'est pas un thème
facile et les premiers discours donne le
ton pour l'instant nous avons amené le
compte administratif 2007 et des points
de ce rapport était bientôt vous le
savez dans un contexte totalement
inédits cette année celui de la mise en
oeuvre de nouvelles lois de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
nous avons un budget qui est résolument
tourné vers les investissements le
département investit lourdement sur le
territoire matière de route en matière
de collèges dans le domaine agricole par
matière d'irrigation et nous avons lancé
un pacte de solidarité avec les communes
de ville qui nous permet aujourd'hui de
venir aussi en aide aux investissements
réalisés sur les territoires ici la
situation est la même depuis plusieurs
années le département investit de façon
optimiste dans l'économie et les
solidarités notamment à travers les
allocations de solidarité mais la
compensation de l'état à cette dépense
se réduit d'année en année mais jusqu'à
quand le fait des économies quand l'état
nous accompagne au mieux parce que ce
sont des dépenses de solidarité
nationale est là l'état fait voter
doivent programmation va en parler tout
à l'heure qui demande département de la
réunion de fait entre 30 millions
d'économies sur ses dépenses de
fonctionnement mais ne veut pas toucher
aux aides qu'on accorde à nos familles
en difficulté on ne veut pas toucher aux
aides qu'on apporte à nos gramounes
personne bénéficiaire donc des airs de
handicap
masson une relation état département pas
facile avec cette volonté de l'état de
réduire la dette publique et ainsi
obliger certaines collectivités à des
économies d'où le débat entre les élus
pour trouver des pistes de solution et
chaque année tout à l'heure quelques
indiens côté il faut choisir entre la
peste et le choléra
moi je dis dans le monde actuel il ya
plus de carottes ya un bâton long we
abattoirs tu peux plus quoi donc ça nous
les prévu pour gagne quand même le tout
aux changements donc moi aujourd'hui
jeudi
les réunionnais ne mérite pas ça
maintenant ils sont suffisamment engagés
sont suffisamment volontaire pour que
dans cette dernière ligne droite de
négociations nous trouvons une le juste
équilibre entre eux oui nous comprenons
les problèmes financiers d'une nation
mais non ne sautons pas qu'on détruise
une population à n'importe quel prix et
en plus la population
après une suspension de séance qui a
permis au chef de groupe d'échangé la
décision est prise
[Musique]
situation de souffrance sociale qui ai
connu six
prochain rendez-vous pour nos élus de 27
juin afin de prendre une ultime décision
avant le vote de cette loi de
programmation des finances publiques dit
de contrat de confiance
[Musique]